definitely going to this folks the
enchant immersive experience in downtown
summerlin basically at the las vegas
ballpark in downtown a holiday event new
to our area but the organizers say with
so many events in town that people love
they hope it will become a tradition for
local families
largest christmas light maze it's also a
local village market as well as ice
skating there's characters there's live
music and amazing drinks
he says it took about 2 million lights
to put it together and the focal point
is a tree in the center that's even
taller than the rockefeller tree
this runs through january 2nd and
tickets are on sale now
the 30th annual magical forest has
returned to opportunity village it is
now open
through january 2nd oh this is so much
fun and obviously for a great cause
tickets are 22 online there's santa of
course 25 dollars at the door
well silverton casino has announced its
plans for the holiday season it all
starts with a tree lighting ceremony
this friday from three to six o'clock
that includes free entertainment cookies
hot cocoa and of course so much more
meanwhile silverson's famous mermaids
will take a break outside their tank to
read holiday stories to kids on
saturdays and sundays and for adults the
bad elf pop-up bar will be in place at
the shady grove lounge
and the fremont street experience is
commemorating the jewish holiday
hanukkah with grand menorah lighting
this weekend it's at 4 30 sunday
afternoon it will be lit and on display
throughout hanukkah
well you can find more information about
these events as well as other things
happening for the holidays on our
website that's 8newsnow.com